you look gorgeous as always and uh
you've got it you got the the red head
look going a little bit here yeah
redhead uh yeah
it's terrible i've never tried that for
real on a woman uh what what uh what's
it like do you is any difference do you
like being a redhead because normally
you're you're blonde i'm a natural
blonde mm-hmm but um bones don't get
treated very well in our society so i i
enjoy being a redhead much more you're
having a better experience with it with
an ipad
i get punched in the head a lot uh
but do you like it did you do you notice
a difference i mean you know some people
think that that that redheads are you
know we're fiery and
do you get people
uh
i no i am not a fiery it used to be you
know as a blonde if i had something i
wanted to say people are like oh she's
high maintenance kind of a you know but
as as a redhead you get she's a
firecracker she is you know right feisty
so you blondes people maybe it's easier
for them to dismiss a blonde but if
you're a redhead they think you got
spunk you got spunk baby yeah yeah yeah
i don't get that either uh you
we do have in common uh i have very very
pale skin and you you seem to have
almost yours is it's beautiful
absolutely gorgeous but almost
translucent well
yeah
i can see your skeleton no uh
my sister calls it fish belly blue which
is that's not nice no it's no but it's
true but fish belly blue goes well with
the red let me tell you much better than
with the blind so did you not like your
growing up because i always find when i
was a kid i don't know how you i mean i
was a redhead and very pale and i hated
the way i looked do you did you growing
up with the pale skin was that fun for
you or i mean i didn't want to be pale
i've accepted it i i didn't do very well
you learned slowly to accept it choice i
mean i my skin repels the sun i
literally like i tried to lay out once
in italy without sunscreen for like 20
minutes at four o'clock in the afternoon
and i got sun poisoning i woke up with a
rash all over so yes yes this is uh this
is turning me on uh
this was my whole experience growing up
was sun for five minutes you know my mom
made me wear like an old lady's big hat
exactly and forget going to the beach in
bikinis like i could never wear a bikini
no
i got yelled at at a water park in
georgia somebody yelled at me to get a
tan and i don't know if you've been to
water parks in georgia but this man was
not much to look at in a swimsuit and
someone yelled at you hey get a tan yes
sir that's terrible it was horrible yeah
right dude what did you do did you say
something really cool back to him i want
no i didn't actually i think i was upset
quietly upset i wanted to like yeah you
know something like hey well
i'm gonna look really good someday and
you'll still be fat you know
[Laughter]
that's good
i think you should have said that i
think i said that to my sister under you
know the tears
you wrote it later on yeah in my memory
that's what i would do i would i would
go later and write that in my room oh
that's what i will say next time exactly
to those cruel bullies exactly um yeah i
have to talk about something again that
affects my life i have a daughter who uh
when saw enchanted when she was i want
to say three
she saw when she was three years old and
absolutely her she just couldn't believe
she just loved the movie and she loved
you in the movie and of course believed
it all and because so much of it happens
in central park and we live near central
park
she then would say to me take me to
central park i want to go find the
princess from enchanted so she's always
looking
for you in central park we should plan
that someday yeah
you know you should charge people like
fifty thousand dollars
which it worth yeah i would only charge
you that much yeah yeah
[Laughter]
thank you you're so nice
i do it for free but for you 50 000.
let's have it
but yeah no i uh it's it's it's been
interesting because kids sometimes
recognize me their parents really do and
i'm always like oh no no i'm in sweats i
look you're going to ruin her whole idea
of princesses and um i met these kids at
an airport and and i had that experience
this i think she must have been three
mm-hmm and they said do you know who
this is it's gisele and she
well done you know that's not giselle
she was really oh really she got upset
she did i was horrified i had to
actually i bent down to her level and i
had to be like you know i'm in disguise
that's so nice of you though that's
really great that she must have loved
that she well her eyes it she sort of
understood right once i was like you
know how i made this out of you know i
made this out of my sofa these sweats
they're made out of much you know that's
so great uh yeah what's good
an airport such a not a good place why
are they making giselle take off her
belt it's security exactly
running a metal detector around her and
now they let paparazzi and they can take
pictures of you sort of like with your
striped socks under your jeans you know
it's very interesting yeah that's that's
a especially barefoot
they take shots of anything out there
but that's so nice that you that you do
that well i i love that i love the
little girl who like this movie and and
you know but you know what's so funny
what i'll sometimes when i'm walking
around people will sometimes you know
the adult will recognize me and then
they'll get their four-year-old good you
know who this is
this is conan o'brien yeah look i'm on
at 12 35 at night
we get a v for violence you know
the kids always i don't care on such a
profound level
it's terrible yeah but it's been fun to
do a film that affects kids and in a
positive way um i want to ask you
something you used to work at the gap
and i want to ask you about that because
i'm always i'm i'm personally fascinated
by people that are so talented they've
become such big stars but just a few
years ago you know
like a lot of people were working a job
nine to five how did you like working at
the gap i i liked it all right i have to
say at the time i'm one of those
personalities i'll try to make the best
of whatever situation so i was the
greeter and so i was always like hey
check out our t-shirts hey we carry
men's underwear now you know i would
think of anything
like anything i could think to say so
your job was to just start a
conversation is that is that the job of
the greeter yes there is i don't i
haven't been there for a while i don't
know if any of you guys have worked at
the gap but there's the gap act which is
greet approach product information
add-on which is that thing you know when
you're in the dressing room they're like
hey you know what look great with those
jeans is this sweater
oh my god
i always think i always think the girl
just thought of that
they're always getting me to buy like a
poncho to go with the socks i know i'm
sure like the gap people will be outside
to whisk me away as i walk out of your
show i've revealed we must remove the
chip from her brain
she's proved troublesome uh yeah so be
nice to them when they that's their job
their managers are making them add the
belt because add-on and then it's closed
and then huh i don't know close means
make sure you get the sale yes that's
why they grab onto your ankles when you
try and leave the store they're hitting
you right i forget what the t is
there's a t in there too well acta yeah
[Laughter]
for me
i should learn to read uh
and a spell um i want to talk about
doubt you're in this uh in this movie
with meryl streep yes it's got to be a
dream come true and i know you're also
working with her in another movie as
well yeah it hasn't come out yet uh
julian julia it comes out in august but
i shot it directly after doubt and that
was fun it involves um
uh we cook a lot and it's about cooking
yeah i cook my way through the julia
child cookbook cool yeah did you learn
to cook anything like what do you learn
amazing skills i did i learned how to
poach an egg
and to make omelets without a spatula
and i learned how to bone a duck
okay
[Applause]
let's talk about doubt uh
i play a nun yeah you you play a nun in
doubt and you really wanted this part
please settle down
you people sick in me maybe i should not
tell them about my
duck boning press no no no no no that
doesn't go with the nun